Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Subnautica.
Now I wanted to thank you guys so much for all of your patience in getting this series back on its feet.
*Occasional Sea Dragon Noises*
We were in Boston a lot longer then we thought we were going to be
and we planned to be there a lot longer-
Ignore the, the dragon that's outside of my doors trying to get into this boat.
Uh, he's an unfriendly neighbor because I'm about to move into the neighborhood here.
Uh, but I just wanted to thank you guys for being so patient and I understand that I left this on a cliffhanger
with, the, uh, research base to explore and the other things that I have in mind.
But first things first, Thank you Moonshine for commenting,
"You got a signal for the alien thermal plant which is a precursor base inside the lava castle,
so the spire formation that you were fighting the sea dragon above with the smoke"-
I like how you say I was "FIGHTING" the sea dragon and not being "MAULED TO DEATH" by the sea dragon.
Being "BEATEN ALIVE" and then "EATEN ALIVE" and then "SHITTEN ALIVE" out into the lava zone,
Uh, and then magically I managed to respawn back into my, my cyclops here, which is a blessing to be sure.
Um, but this base is NOT the containment facility.
That is in the active lava zone.
Apparently I'm not in the "active" lava zone.
So as some of you may have already known, and as I was rambling on about in the livestream yesterday for about 10 years,
I'm sick.
I have the flu,
and Amy now has the flu too, and she was so nice to take care of me while I was sick,
and then she got the flu, so I am going to me taking care of her while she recovers.
But I did get some time to record this.
Uh so I also want to thank Ethan Garak who said in the inactive lava zone,
multiple reaper leviathans skeletons can be found.
This is due to sea dragons coming up from the lava zone to catch them,
then drag them down to the lava zone to feast.
That's a horrifying thought,
because if the dragon's only diet is reaper leviathans, then what chance do I have?
Why in the hell did I go out there and scan that damn thing
if it was just going to eat more reaper leviathans?
I mean the enemy in my enemy might be my friend
but this guy doesn't seem to have any friends at all.
And I think if I go near him he's just gonna kill me
over and over again.
So anyway, he's out there, and I think my lights are off,
Uuuh, not that that's gonna help anyway.
So, that's a terrifying thought.
Also, to Noah Dawson who said something that just made me laugh,
"Don't shamwoozle the bamboozle"
which I think is life lessons for everybody out there.
And then Swag Potato who said,
"Mark in a nutshell: So that was really stupid. I'm gonna go do it again,"
which does apply because I went back out into the cold to take pictures of myself
with less and less clothing progressively throughout the day, which is probably why I'm sick.
But then again, everybody got sick from that PAX and this was a particularly bad one.
So, with that being said I'm gonna let you guys know what my plan is and right now,
my plan is to get the hecky away from wherever the hell that dragon is.
I hope he's not immediately below me, because that's where I'm gonna go.
Well shit. No I'm not.
It is re-god-damn dark out down here.
Okay, yeesh. Someone's unhappy with meeee.
Okay, so what I'm gonna do down here--
Oh, I might as well make it right by this skeleton.
You know, I might have a nice lawn ornament--
So when I said I was gonna be moving into the neighborhood, that means exactly what
you think it means. I'm going to be building a base down here, and make it my new home.
I'm never-ever gonna have to leave.
I've got seeds with which to plant trees.
Hopefully there's titanium down here but who knows about that.
Maybe the titanium's all melted down because of the LAVA.
But imma try my best and that's all I can hope to do.
So I'm gonna scow--oh hey
At least I've got my friendly neighborhood Warper.
You frickin' douchebag.
So what I need to do...
is I need to scout an amicable location for my base--
(To Warper) Aw thanks!
He doesn't like this place, the heat gets to him--
And then once I do that,
of which it's going to be boiling hot so I gotta take my ah,
my Mr. Fister here
I'm gonna...
Start gathering materials!
(Computer) Welcome aboard Captain
Which is my favorite thing to do in the middle of a death-defying area where there's
Dragons abound...
..and Warpers--
Why?
Oh god dammit!
It's doing that thing again!
It's doing that thing again where it doesn't have the pressure modulator on it and I don't know why!
Frickin bugs.
Alright so I gotta access the uh...
I gotta access the upgrade hatch somehow.
Frick.
I guess I just gotta hop in there, get out, and do it.
Alright, you know what, Imma go for it.
Here we go!
Hibbidy hobbidy hibbidy hobbidy HIIB (fart noise)
Okay, so we just gotta pop this b-
Ow my skin is burning.
That's great, that's good for ya.
So we gotta pop this back in and out here,
and I'm going to umm
Nah, that's good enough for me.
Oh, I'm burning alive!
Get- NOO that's not what I want.
Can you not do that?  That'd be good.
Okay, thank you for that.
Alright, so now that my pressure, for some reason, is magically now appropriate,
I'm gonna explore this hellscape and call it:
Home.
Ah, yes,
Lovely.
I'm sure he died fun.
What is this?
Is that uh...
Uh, that's diamond.
That's not what I want.
Can I get some titanium out of this sunabitch?
Nope!
Okay, this might be--
This might be a--
This might be a lost cause trying to do this.
But if there's one thing that Markiplier doesn't do, it's give up,
especially when it's a stupid idea.
So I'm gonna keep hammering away at this stupid idea,
until I find a source of titanium,
with which I can...
build a base...
(Low Grunting Noise)
I hate this place. I hate everything about this place.
And supposedly I'm nearby the uh,
I'm nearby- oh
*Sea Dragon roar*
Apparently I'm nearby--oh
That guy is mad.
That guy is REAL mad.
oohh
Well that is--
Hey is that a skull?
Heh, that'd be a nice--
That'd be a nice thing to wake up next to every morning and look at.
Oh that's beautiful-- and laggy.
Ahhh.
Two frames a second, my favorite.
There we go.
Ugh, that one's infected with the Carar.
So yeah, I'm uh-
yeah, okay, I've uh got no hope is basically-
Get out of my face, you wanna get some suckage?
Go suck away somewhere else, ya asshole.
Alright, I can't-- (referring to Dragon) I don't know where that guy is,
but I can't wait to try to fall asleep to those sounds.
Just a Sea Dragon screaming in the distance as loud as it can.
Ugh, what is this?
*Sea Dragon roars*
Where is this?
Where is this going?
Oh, quit moanin'!
I've got the FLU, you think I care about YOUR problems?
Not you guys, his problem.
Man, you are just a whiny bitch today!
Can you just-
M-M-M-M-Man or woman up, whatever you are
and then just be brave?
Sto- wo, Hey, WOH, WOH!
What the hell was that?
Excuse you!
Don't make me scan you.
I'll do it, I'm brave like that.
You want me to scan you..?
HOWH-I bet u don't I bet u just shy......
Hurh
(Sarcastic Tone) Oh, no! You took a bite! Oh, it did almost something!
Oh ow! Ooh! Oh yeah that hurt.
*Fake moans*
I need to repair this thing.
Maybe he was hurting me, I have no idea.
OH GOD HE IS, OKAY, HE HURTS ME! OKAY!
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M GONNA GRIND YOU!
Yeesh.
Okay, that guy hurt a lot...
Don't you even frickin dare destroy this thing, IT'S ALL I HAVE!
YEEEEEE IT'S ALL I HAVE, DON'T HIT ME!
Aww come on!
Why is someone such a whiny baby?!
Man! He's whining up a storm!
Holy shit that guy is grumpy!
Ohhhh, he's up there-
Are there two of them? Are they mating!?
Is there a mating ritual going on of Sea Dragons of epic proportions that I don't want to be around for?
Uhhh, Alright, pull me in.
Come on!
No, that's, that's the stupid way to do it.
Nah, that's the outside. I like how you missed the hole there, that was good!
Lag's perfect-- yeah that's it!
Hupp!
Yeah we made it, okay we'll call that one a good.
Ooohh.
Oh.
Hang on, wait a second.
Alien thermal plant!
Oh! I am right by it!
Oh, you know, I might as well go over there...
Might as well skedaddle and see what that's all about, because that's gotta be fun!
A whole plant dedicated to thermal!
Huh!
Can you umm...
If you're gonna be here then I might as well name you!
I'm gonna call you...
Little...
Li- Little Larva Larry.
Nah, I named a lot of things Larry, I don't wanna name you Larry too...
I'm gonna call you...
Little Lar- Little Larva Lester!
After my Favorite Youtuber Phil Lester.
So far I'm just skirting around this big spiral-
I honestly didn't know that I was fighting over in that- the big pillars of smoke were
the exhaust tubes for the thermal plant.
So what I gotta do is I gotta find the entrance wherever the hell it is.
*Mumbling* I don't even know-
I don't even know how I got these co-ordinates. They were just in my inventory.
What do you think, Lester? Huh?
Little Larva Lester! Oh, you're gonna be a plushie soon!
Everyone is gonna have this horrible thing that will just suck...
All the power out of them.
Nah, that's a bad idea!
Nooo, hey, okay.
That was a thing that happened.
OHH I'M IN THE MIDDLE OF A DRAGON!
I didn't realize that!
Ohh, okay, sorry, excuse me.
Please do not bat me around
you can't hurt me. I'm in my-
Oh hey, okay.
Alright, that was weird.
Okay so maybe I was on the correct side.
Is there something, oooh wait I see something up there!
Ahhhhh!
HELLO, HELLO, HELLO!
My name is Markiplier!
... How are you doing?
Ahh yes!
I will enter this weird...
Geologically bizarre place.
Okay, Alright then. I wish I could repair my doodydadder, that'd be awfully nice.
But I can't.
And my inventory is full, why is my inventory full?
I gotta drop off some shit.
Argh, I keep wasting my time like this.
Okay, so we're gonna go into this bad boy.
and then I'm going to do what I need to do, and if I need a key I'm going to be screwed,
because I don't think I have enough diamond for that...
OH WHAT AM I TALKING ABOUT. There is diamond everywhere here.
This is literally the only place where diamond is in excess.
So...
I- I'm gonna make that if I need to make that-
but I don't know if I need to make that yet, so I'm gonna hold off on that until I KNOW I need to make that.
Then I'm gonna take Mr. Fister in there and hopefully repair him on the way out.
LET'S DO THIS!!!
Come on!!!!
I'm ready for ya.
WE'RE ready for it.
Whatever's in here--
Whoa 'kay.
Alright, faster than I thought.
Okie dokie!
Love the decor!
Ahhh...
This looks horrifying.
Oh goody!
I hope I die here!
Ahhhh
*Sea Dragon roars*
I see it's haunted by the screams of the damned.
Woah woah, laggy...
Almost sent me into the abyss!
Okay then...
Well this is promising!
So...
I'm in here-
but what else is in here?
Oh, it just keeps going down.
Eughhh
OHHH there we go!
That looks weird and scary
Eughhh
Just like everything else here so I guess it kinda fits.
I'm just looking for anything that might be titanium which is what i might need if i ever wanna make a base down here
OHH MY GOD!!!
How did you make this in here?
How'dya do this!?!
I mean I'm about to build a base down here, so -i would like some tips, some pointers would be great!
Is there diamond in here?
... might need that...
Yes there is!
But I'm gonna ROAST ALIVE, 'cause I didn't get my thermal suit
Alright
How do we get into that son-of-a-bitch up there?
Whooo
I'm flying!
Detecting alien materials and a massive local energy mass in the
1,000 megawatt range
NO, I'M FALLING!
1,000 megawatts sounds like a lot, but I have no point of reference to compare it to
so I'm gonna assume that it's not as much as
as I produce
Alright so what do we got?
Plooms of lava
Precurser architecture
Ooh
Why are you here?
WHOA
woah
God damn it
don't don't don't do not
DOONN'T
NOOOO
NOOOOOOO
oh no no no!
Oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
I need to repair this
GET UP THERE, YOU SON OF A BITCH
GET UP THERE!
Or down
Down's good too you know!
Whatever gets me away from the son of a bitch that-
Put me at one fucking percent
Just get me the fuck out of here!
Aaah!
PULL ME PULL ME PULL M-
OH MY GOOOOD
I'm just gonna reload my save D:
That wasn't my fault!
I was trying to sit on a ledge!
So that I could repair
I don't know why-
But it would not let me get on a ledge
and for some reason, there was no fish around me that blew me up
I just blew up!
Why?
I have no god damn idea!
Why would I have just blown up?!
That makes no sense!
Why did I just blow up?!
I don't know!
Ask the game!
I don't- I didn't do it, I didn't choose to blow up!
Why would I have chosen to blow up?!
Blowing up is the opposite of what I wanted to dooo!
*mumbles* Alright, fine then
Ok, so that went poorly
But I'm gonna be right back to it
Don't you worry!
You don't go nowhere
Oh look I'm back!
I'm not yet
*Mumbles* It's a magic trick
OOO I see an entrance
I'm here!
I've made it!
Welcome me!
Ok, I can probably-
Did you guys hear that?
Sounded like something horrible!
HORRIBLE AND HORRIFYING!
TERRIBLE EVEN!
Sounded like bad!
B for Bad?
Like a whole lot of bad
Something's moving around in here and I don't like it
Ok
So that is nothin- Oh hey that's not- that's not- that- I don't like the look-
I'm gonna get in my suit now!
I'm gonna get in my suit now and beat the shit out of you if you try to come by me
What the friick are youu
Cool tunes
ok
I don't know what you are but I'm gonna try to scan you!
Alien drone?
HELL YEAH, GET SCANNED
Uh huh, ok, alright then
Neato
Neato Burrito!
What do ya got for me
This device does not match any known humon technology
Although its design is relatively simple
Its only observed behavior has been attacking local liveforms in a radius around the ancient structures
Features few moving parts
Carries a rechargeable, ion-based power reserve
Reliable and energy efficient.
Modeling the age and purpose of the device is difficult
Its relative harmlessness is at odds with the advanced technology apparently available to its designers
Ok, so
Advanced technology needs to be harmful, is that what you're saying?
I think not!
Ok, wow well this is- this is weird
Aha! Ok, so there is something in here that needs to be-
Accessed with a- Oh!
Yeah, I don't have a purple artiact
But I can get one
What the frick is this?
Woah! It's the MotherLOAD!
What is that?!
Hey, Hey wha- OW!
OW!
MAH ASS
Stop it, hey, stop it, oh, cut you!
Hiyah! Hiyah!
Yeah, you better run
Huh, oh, floating on nothing then oh alright... (mumbles)
Alright so, what I don't have..
Is the key so I'm going to go get that
And get some diamond on the way. So I'll be right baack
cause I need to make this adventure
(Rip headphone users)
Almost! Something about this place and getting me over the edge of stuff is real hard D:<
This is a- this is a complicated area getting me over like, ledges and cresipises and all that
Yeah ok, that that that made sense, ok we'll do it that way if that's what you wanna do
Ok!
Soo
I don't know why that's doing that
Alright!
So I'm in here!
If anybody wants to fight-
Gets to answer to Mr.Fister! D:<
You wanna fight? I'll fight you, i'll fight you, i'll fight you! WwHAAAA
Get rekt :D
You're dead
That's what'll happen to youu
That's what'll happen to ALL of you!
If you even come close to me! >:D
Hey, is that that thing that's supposed to be the power of a nuclear bomb?
What happens if I hit it with my
with my
drill
Let me save before I hit it with my drill, but what happens if I hit this with my drill?
(The world ends)
Huh?
Is it gonna be all bull- shploady?
I bet it is >:D
Oh HELL yeah!
Gimmy your ions!
Fuc yeah dude!
Oh, fuc yeah! :D
Oh, Hell yeah!
This doesn't seem responsible, ya know!
I'm gonna just go ahead and say that-
When I approach alien technology with the power of multible
You know nuclear explosions
Don't go hitting it with a diamond drill!
That's probably rule number one
Well I don't know, what do I know, I'm just a dumb humon!
These Precursors, they probably accounted fer
Barbaric other species (you mean you, mark?)  smacking away at their energy sources
I mean, it's so weird
Cause the accounted for this
Like, the developers anyway, they accounted for, uh
Yaven coming here with a
fricken
Drill!
But uh, now I got this!
And hopefully- hopefully this means I'll be able to get- um
Get the
WAAAAAA, you are KIDDING MEE
I hate youu (aww D:)
I hate all of youu!
D':
I hate youu
How could you do this to me?
(I'm sorry D':) How could you do this to mee?
I made my misitakes! Whoops, I got nowhere to run apparently
Welp! I fell down, went boom
Uh, speed runners, take note of this for anyone trying to speedrun
Well, that looks cool, good thing I saw that before I was supposed to
You know, get there
That's- that's a good, you know I'm gonna just
just wander around
Mark noises
You know what this stuff reminds me of?
Creepers
Like, look at the skin pattern, with the pixels, the squares in there
the subtle green shifting
the explosive potential of power
Kinda creeperesk
Got a litte bit of creeper going on in there
Mark sounds
Ok, did I blow it all up?
Good, ok, alright
Give, give, give give give
Give give give. And then don't send me off into the abyss, I don't even know how you did that
Ok
So now that I got that I can actually maneuver my way into here
Hob ba da boop boop
(Sings) Get in there, let me in
I'm hoping that maybe the- the
Unless, I've gotten it already, but I don't think I've gotten it
the design for the- um
Bwa- whoa
Blue?
Blue artfact?
Blu- Oh it's big! :D
Ancient alien artifact, glows blue
Wow, thanks for telling me more about that- that seems really cool that you
went to all the trouble of writing that in intense detail about it
Thank you!
I feel learned did
I feel like my brain has expanded in compasity
Numerous times :D
Oh, wait, is this a gate?
Wade a minute, wade a minute, wade a minute, is this a gatey gate? :D
Is this a gaaa- how do I turn it on, where does it go to?
Ah
If this leads to the surface, it is-
A god send
It is amazing- I am almost stuck again D:<
But, if this is a gate
And it does lead to somewhere on the surface, I'm going to be so happy
I don't see a way to turn it on here
So maybe there is a way turn it on somewhere else
Yeah I don't see anything
that I can place
ok
So, I'm going to come back to this, but that's
that's actually good
And I'm going to save again because I don't want to save and have everything expload again! :D
ok
So, that's- that's good to know. There's another way to go down there but I'm gonna go this way first
Just to check it all out
Oh, ok. this is just another side entrance, ok
Good to know, good to know, good to know. Good to know!
Not that I need to know right now, but that's good to know
Hipody hop down the candy shop!
Alright, what do we got here? Does anything need a blue artifact key down here?
So I'm thinking
Just judging by what- uh uh, moonshine said
I don't think this is the containment plant, I think this is
only
this- this whole purpose of this particular
(Mark makes a discovery) I needed two!
I needed two!
I called that! I didn't know that
I called it :D
Hell to the yeah!
I'll take that, why not
Alright!
(Voice breaks) Cool!
(Amazed) I got it!
But uh, I'm beginning to think that their might be another one- uh
Somewhere far off
Ugh, I apologize, I'm feeling sick, getting uh- getting energized like this
Ooooo
Oo, ok, alright, I'll read
This
This system converts thermal energy to electric current at 90% efficiency
Some of this energy is chemically stored on sight
While unknown mechanisms appear to be transferring most of it to remote locations somewhere else on the planet
30% percent stored on sight for emergency use
30% Ground-to-air quarantine enforcement platform
22% primary containment facility
11% disease research facility
7% self-warping quarantine units
ah
This system appears to be fully automated and given current understanding of the mechanisms involved
uninterruptable
interesting!
So this is providing power to the warpers
uh
remotely
I don't know how it does that
Obviously, this  a game world, so you know
It does it through game logic but
Just through sheer technology alone like
That's a really fascinating utilization of wireless power
which is a concept that does exist
uh, But only in limited circumstances like
uh, it is kinda fascinating
Oo, maybe it's gonna tell me how
Oo- ok I'll read this, sure
This geological data was recorded from the volcanic rock that was excavated to construct this facility
It was possible to extrapolate a number of key trends
Genetic Divergence
The aliens recorded data on indigenous organic remains originating between 10,000 and 1,000 years ago
The lifeforms on record feature an unusually low overlap with those encountered so far on 4546B
So
there are very few species
from 1,000 years ago that even exist today. Very few.
Extinction Event
Soil samples from 1,000 years ago contain 300% higher concentrations organic remains than the soil average
Data supports a mass extinction event killing off a majority of species and forcing rapid adaptation amongst many of the survivors.
Cause is unknown.
Plausible theories include
Fluctuating environmental conditions, Disease, meteor impact, Outside interference
So the outside interference would have been
the precursers  but it also could have been the carar
because they were reasearching the carar
disease like
what was it?
1,000 years ago, and then 1,000 years ago there was an extinction event
So then the majority of the species died
But for there to be any life now , even if it's very different from the life that exists
then
it would've had to
been resistant to the disease
So why is it starting to affect everything now
is the question
did I have something to do with that? Or maybe they contained it
And then I accidently, oopsy boopsy, unleashed it
which would be-
expected of me, I'm a doof :D
Oh! Thanks for the lighted- lighted hallways! I wouldn't have know where to go ^-^
Ooo, this looks important!
Alien ion crystal data! There we go, is that gonna be the stuff I need?
This alien-
This alien data reveals some of the mechanisms by which the designers were able to contain and harness such vast amounts of energy within the ion crystals discovered around their facilities
Improved battery and power cell blueprints which take advantage of this information are now available for fabrication
HEYYY
There we go! :D
I have the stuff now! Cool!
So now I can make these- new power cells
And new ion batteries
And then those are gonna be much more efficient in all the devices
So, you guys have been telling me that I can make these things
I haven't been able to make these things because I never got them from here
ahh
but that's cool
ok
So I'm all out of time for this episode. I think I reached the bottom of this except for that one other area
trying to get that gate
unlocked
But I'll figure that out in the next episode and in the next episode as well
I'll be building a base down here
I don't know how many trips I'm gonna need to go back up to get enough titanium to do that
hopefully just one and then load up my entire cyclops
but
I'm gonna do that because I'm going to fight D:<
that son of a bitch
known as the sea dragon
don't know if it's possible to kill it, but ima gonna fight it and I'm gonna try to kill it
So how about that
(Outro)
Buh Bye! :D
*rad outro music plays*
Goodnight everyone! ^-^